Hungarian Prime Minister Viktor Orban
likes to see himself as a man of action
doing things like building a pipeline
he's making an appearance for the
opening of a section of the north-south
gas corridor conveniently timed for this
weekend's election but like many things
in Hungary these days appearances can be
deceptive or bands pipeline is supposed
to transport gas from Croatia but the
other end remains a pipe dream because
no agreements have been signed with the
Croatian government and foreign
investors are avoiding hungry for
another reason all bands nationalist
conservative government has introduced
what they call discriminatory taxes the
oven by the bank and they have
introduced new taxes at the banks and
the telecom company fees that are being
passed on to us and are actually a
burden to us spider-girl itit Wooden's
in tho practice UNS balusters thought
and um it Imre Nagy runs a small company
making electronic products for retailers
in Germany he says his costs have shot
up by twenty percent under or bans
regime but all bands narrative is that
he has lifted the country out of an
economic crisis he cites lower
unemployment as proof but Nagy says his
company can barely hold on to its
workforce we feel there are loads of
statistics floating around and lots of
propaganda the media sounds upbeat but
unfortunately it's far from the truth
VAR hate East Atlas under Slater the
truth say many looks more like this
legions of men in fluorescent vests sent
to work in Budapest cleaning parks the
situation is not sustainable though oh
yeah sure unemployment is officially
lower because of 250,000 municipal
workers like us they also count people
who've left the country the statistics
are being manipulated
an estimated half a million Hungarians
left the country last year in search of
work they're qualified workers who would
normally have no problem finding jobs
with multinationals in Hungary so
there's real cause for concern as Latin
ageru yo we are seeing that these
international companies are the most
competitive part of the hungry economy
to keep penalizing them is a huge
problem in the long term because not
enough capital is entering the country
we need that to create jobs and growth
shows a thought Oliver Kadisha could add
a shameful mother but there doesn't seem
to be much chance of any Swift
fundamental change polls suggest
Hungary's current government will be
voted in for another term